So please join the live lectures only using your registered ID as standard is tracked
only with the registered ID and the login ID which you have purchased for the course.
If you have joined with registered ID, it will be captured, that ends will be captured and
you check any spelling mistakes when you enter during the session.
Otherwise, sign out from the login and re-login with the exact login ID.
So each every web page session will be unique and shared every week over email, community
and from course batch.
To set up the WebEx layout option for learners, go to the layout option showing it on the
screen at the top right hand side, click on the stack mode, again click on the stack mode
and below that you can see this enable full screen mode.
So just enable that also.
This will show you it in full screen mode for the presenter of the presenter.
So please put your queries in Q&A session.
So please be assured that if professors are unable to attend all your queries in Q&A session,
it will be answered and uploaded in our discussion room.
So for the assignment availability for the week 2, assignment will be enabled at 2 p.m.
For the week 1 assignments that mission deadline on 16th February that is tomorrow at 11 p.m.
And solution for the week 1 assignment will be available 17th February that is Monday
by 11 a.m.
So assignment evaluations will be done by IATKHB professors prior to the conclusion of the
course and will be made available on the portal.
You can access the evaluation commands once the assignment has been evaluated.
So kindly refer reference materials from course batch.
We'll walk into the portal.
You can go to the course batch.
You can refer the materials from reference section.
And other documents, pre-read materials will be available in the discussion room and answers
for the question answers, important supporting documents will be available in community.
So all the important documents are tagged in the highlight section for easy access.
Today we have a quiz for the week 1, so this will be available today, Saturday, 15th February
2025 between 5 p.m. till 7 p.m.
The duration of the quiz will be 30 minutes.
So once you start that quiz, you should complete before 30 minutes, within 30 minutes.
Please ensure your network availability and the power backup during that taking that quiz.
Please try to attend your quiz by desktop only.
So don't try it in mobile, it's for better or easy access.
So results for that assessment quiz will be available at 9 p.m. on the same day.
To view the marks obtained, click on the terms taken, you'll be able to see the quiz answers.
Then WhatsApp notification adjusts will be sent only for those who have given consent
in the platform.
So please log into the platform, give the consent that I will show you during the break
time.
So you can give the notification adjust.
You will be getting the notification adjust only after giving the consent.
In case of any issues, if you want to connect with us, please reach out to us info.tcs.nobla.tcs.com.
Once again, thank you all for joining today's session.
Sir, over to you.
Okay.
Thank you.
Yes.
So today we are going to start a new session.
As a statistical learning, we will talk about its fundamental aspects which are essential
for not only statistical understanding, but it is the foundation for machine learning especially.
We will try to bridge the gap between the languages where the machine learning practitioners
use and the statisticians use such that the flow of the understanding will be smooth.
And people have a more transparent perspective over the context.
So first let us start with statistical learning.
The learning procedure mostly in machine learning setup, it is a generalization from learning
by memorization to learning by generalization.
So initially whatever the information is gathered and passed to the machine, the extension
of that information for those segments of the data where the information is not available,
that is the job a machine learning problem must do.
And if we have little bit more prior knowledge about the mechanism, then it might create
certain bias based on the prior information or it may sync with the new data that are
coming to it.
So now when do we need to do the machine learning when the tasks are too complex or to be constructed
in one program and when the situations are adaptive.
I assume that in future courses, the experts will talk more details about these different
types of learning, but before going to that we just touch upon the aspects such that we
can connect it to the statistical aspect.
So most of the cases we divide the learning process either supervised learning or unsupervised
learning, in supervised learning the label to the data are present as a consequence at
the end of the day it becomes easier to train the data and to the segregation.
You can consider that classification problem is one of the supervised learning regression
problem is a supervised learning problem, but unsupervised learning where the levels
are not present to the data and from the data itself machine has to identify certain features
and segregate them in different buckets that is unsupervised learning.
So as a consequence the clustering can be considered as an unsupervised learning.
Now active and passive this is also another story which is similar to the previous one
when it is passive learning most of the cases levels are present, but when it is active
learning that the machine not only should learn the feature they also start to categorization
and rectify the information that they have it has gathered and modify it accordingly.
Then teacher student model when there is a large model already existing and we want to
implement a part or the entire model to another setup then there is a teacher student type
of model we call where a complete scenario is known, but something new is dataset is
there we want to invoke the existing infrastructure and the mechanism for the new setup and there
the teacher student model often used.
And online and batch learning in statistics online learning is also sometime known as the
surveillance problem and batch learning is known as the retrospective study.
So this is very important for signal detection as well as the machine learning problem sorry
not as well as the medical research.
So in the online problem the data are updated in a sequential order and the information are
also get enhanced as a consequence the inform the conclusion becomes dynamic.
On the other hand batch learning as it is retrospective we assume that a certain segment
of the data available we do analysis of the entire data as a whole in batch learning problem.
I am sure that future days the experts will go in deep with this type of learning processes
we are today we are going to make connection this type of thing with the statistical learning.
So what is the essence of statistical learning?
So we typically want to estimate some function that is the ultimate goal and that function
here we call it in short here we call it f some unknown function it could be anything
the purpose is mostly two one is prediction another is inference prediction means based
on that function f whatever the model we get from this f.
So f is for the model so f is for the model and from that model whatever prediction we
can do given one variable predict for the other that is known as the prediction problem.
So based on the model on the model predict one variable or more than one variable given
the other or other more than one variables we can do.
And inference is talking about the specification of model parameter.
So in short if we give an example the regression is a very prominent example we want to fit
a regression for that there will be certain function and based on an input variable or
the regression variable or the feature variable we want to predict the response variable that
is a prediction problem and whether a feature variable is will be present in the regression
model or not the coefficient associated to that feature variable is significant enough
or not.
So that is an inferential problem which is also crucial because if we do not require
a parameter or a feature in the model but still we keep on collecting the data that
means it will require a space in the storage it will require time for the collection and
fetching and retrieving and processing the data will be unnecessary which we do not want
for the sake of complexity of the problem.
In a broader sense we can address this problem in two different ways one is the parametric
method another is the non-parametric method when we talk about the parametric method the
models are driven by parameter often we write in the form f theta in such that theta is
the parameter and f is the function dependent on theta and there will be variable x y so
on and so forth associated to the function and non-parametric is the setup where definitely
there will be a function f which is also dependent on the variables but no such parameter is
associated with it but the restriction is often done like that f is continuous or f
is twice so f f prime f double prime exist so these type of assumptions are often made
to establish the mathematical theory for non-parametric setup and rest of the story goes for the
large number so establishment of the I mean the nice behavior for non-parametric method
often we require the large numbers which are not a problem and nowadays because of the
computer that we have plenty of data unless otherwise there is a specific type of problem
like biomedical problem or at the same time maybe say some sociological data analysis
so though in those cases really sometime the problem the data set is small so I hope I
could make little bit clear about the setup that there is a parametric structure to address
the problem there is a non-parametric structure the non-parametric structure flexibility is
more precision is comparatively less parametric structure if the assumption is correct the
precision is very high but if the assumption is wrong then definitely the precision is
low we will try to establish all those thing in a formal way now let us enter in the parametric
structure so whatever we consider as learning eventually in statistical term it is an estimation
problem so in estimation problem specifically for the parametric structure what we consider
that data given then model assumed and parameters estimated.
So try to see the entire structure that the data set is present with us and we have assumed
that the data are coming from a particular model there is no guarantee that the model
will be correct there is a method for validation definitely but at the very beginning there
is no guarantee that the model will be correct and then finally we estimate the model parameters
and find do the validation.
Now here is a catch now there is a catch that whether we will directly jump into the problem
for estimating the function or we can do it in a different way so the parametric structure
in non-parametric structure it is the way that we directly jump to the estimation of
the function but in a non-parametric structure there is certain flexibility.
So what we call demonstrate in this way so suppose this is the parameter space so this
is this thing we write as a script theta which is the parameter space.
On the other hand this is the function space or the model space ok so this is the model
space now suppose if I choose one point in the if I choose one point in the parameter
space that will be associated one model in the model space.
So there will be a one to one connection and if there is more than one parameter which
is giving only same model then that will be trouble so it is supposed to be one to one
mapping otherwise there will be trouble.
And with the advantage of this one our goal is to construct an estimation method such
that we can go to the true parameter in a very steady rate such that if I go to the
true parameter then we will converge to the true model we will also converge we will also
converge to the true model with a very high accuracy that is the fundamental idea.
So for example if I consider this regression structure which is very simple suppose a simple
linear regression structure data are scattered and we have a line.
So this line has a intercept and a slope.
So eventually it is beta naught plus beta 1 x this line.
Now this is the model space ok corresponding parameter space is this one that in 2D this
is beta naught line this is beta 1 line.
So for this straight line I have one point beta naught beta 1.
So one point here is giving one model here if I consider another point here that might
give certain different line here ok.
So that is the fundamental idea that if I have a point here I will get one model there.
Now if I approach to this point one beta naught beta 1 vector is approaching to this point
then gradually the lines will also become very close to this one and finally overlap
with that line.
So this this is the story of entire estimation problem or model parameter learning problem.
So gradually let us make it formal and try to explain the necessary terminologies which
will be useful for better understanding in future.
So this is how the parameter space and the model are associated with.
We will study few things which are the definition of the estimator estimator for the parameter,
some good properties of an estimator and different model estimation problem.
One is moment based estimation problem and rest are MLE and least square as an example
we will discuss both of them can be clubbed together under one umbrella which is known
as M estimator.
And when we say it is an M estimator it means that we get the estimator the choice of the
estimator after minimization or maximization of certain type of function.
In general it might be considered as a cost function but we get the estimator through
minimization or maximization so either minimization or maximization so this is the problem.
So let us start with the definition of an estimator to define an estimator first we
introduce a terminology which is known as statistic remember that s is not here only
up to c statistic a statistic is a function of data it is a function of data only if some
parameter value is known it could be involved there but if the parameter value is not known
then we should not consider it as a statistic and if a statistic is used for estimation
of a parameter or a function of a parameter then it is known as a estimator of that parametric
function.
So here we have written in general g theta g theta can be theta only and tx is statistic
which is a function of data if the data value is known then statistic itself has only one
value the statistic has only one value but if we consider the statistic as a function
of random variable then it is also a random variable.
So given the values of the data the statistic can take only one value given one set of data
but on the other hand if we consider the data in the form of random variable then the statistic
itself is a random variable and it will have a distribution so it is a random variable
and this one is a particular value, okay.
Given the data it is a particular value and in general it is a random variable.
So how to conceptualize the thing, suppose we are addressing a problem and each of you
each candidate of you are addressing the same problem.
So each of you are collecting data separately constructing the same statistic you know the
model you know everything how to do the analysis.
So you collect the data individually you collect go and for the field for survey and collect
the data and finally construct the test statistic to estimate the parameter.
So here you consider the situation which is very much obvious that each of you will get
different data and as you get different data that estimated value will be different for
each of you but each of you have only one data.
Now if we collect all the data or the all the all the statistic value that you have
calculated then and club together all the values then it is you will find a distribution
and the distribution will be the distribution of this random variable which is T of X, okay.
So now let us move forward for more formal definition, okay.
So before we go let me just give you one example such that which is a statistic which is not
a statistic it will be little bit clear.
So for example let us consider that X1, X2, Xn are random samples
from say normal mu sigma square where mu unknown sigma square unknown.
So here very simply I can write one function which is xi minus x bar whole square i running
from 1 to n 1 upon n and another function 1 upon n sum over xi minus x bar sorry xi
minus mu whole square i running from 1 to n. So as mu unknown this is a statistic and
this is not a this is not a statistic because mu is an unknown parameter which is involved
here, here only the data present no unknown parameter present hence it is a statistic.
And if the mu value known then also it will become a statistic otherwise not and if mu
known or mu unknown this could be used as an estimator of sigma square.
So this could be used as an estimator of sigma square but this could be used as an estimator
of sigma square only when mu know can be used as an estimator of sigma square when and in
that case it will become also a statistic. So that is the fundamental difference between
the notion of statistic and the estimator as an application of statistic.
Now few properties which we desire that an estimator will have the first and foremost
is the unbiasedness. So unbiasedness of an estimator eventually demands a theoretical
requirement which says that the expectation of the statistic value is same as the parameter
value or the function of the parameter value. And if it holds for all parameter theta then
only we will call it is an unbiased estimator. So otherwise it will not be considered as
an unbiased estimator. Now suppose let us have an example that X1, X2 again Xm random
square then notice that if I write this quantity sum over Xi square I running from 1 to n 1
upon n. So average of Xi square. So first of all it is a statistic. Without any doubt
it is a statistic. Now if I want to estimate sigma square can I use this one what will
be the situation. So notice that if I take the expectation so I can use definitely because
it is a statistic I can make use of it for estimating sigma square.
But if I want to study its feature if 1 to n expectation of Xi square which is integration
or whatever here from definition you can very easily go that expectation of Xi square I
running from 1 to n which is 1 upon n each of the term is mu square plus sigma I running
from 1 to n as a consequence it is mu square plus sigma. So definitely it is not an unbiased
estimator of sigma square. So it is not an unbiased estimator of sigma square because
you see that some added quantity is present. Now suppose if mu equal to 0 then expectation
of 1 upon so let us call gx or maybe some other function we are saying t. So let us call t
1x expectation of t 1x is sigma square. But notice only when mu is specified to 0 it is
able to estimate unbiased lift for sigma square. But in general it is not true notice the condition
that expectation of tx equal to g theta for all theta. So here in this example what is
theta? Theta is a two component vector mu and sigma square. So for all possible values
tx is expectation of tx the mean of tx is not sigma square only for a particular value
of mu it is sigma square. So in general tx is not an unbiased estimator.
So there is a bias and the bias is mu square, mu square is the bias. So which is the gap
between the true value and the expected value that is known as the bias of the estimator.
And this is a technical statement that even though the estimator is unbiased estimator
it will exactly take the value of the true parameter that probability can be 0 ok. So
those who are little bit advanced in this area may focus on this otherwise it is not
necessary. Then we will come to the consistency.
Now before going to that let us try to see it another example. So here what we have seen
that we cannot estimate sigma square by the help of averaging Xi square variance we cannot
estimate by the averaging Xi square. Now can we to go in a different way if I consider
t2 of the data as x bar square which is 1 upon n sum over Xi I running from 1 to n and
then take the square. So consider the difference, here I have made the square then I have taken
the average, here I am doing the average and then I am taking the square.
Now if you look at any probability book that is suggested here x bar is following normal
mu sigma square by n. So in that situation this symbol is well accepted symbol and it
says that x bar follows normal mu sigma square by n. So as a consequence whatever we are
seeing here that if we take expectation of x bar square which will be no sorry which
will be mu square plus sigma square by n. So this quantity we can use so let us consider
a different way that can be used as an estimator of let us say we are talking about mu square.
So mu square hat is this one. Now notice this thing that this quantity is also biased but
the advantage is this that sigma square by n is going to 0 decreasing to 0 as n is increasing
to infinity. So that is what an advantage to us.
So we were willing to summarize the thing in this way that if we want to estimate mu
square again if we can use this expression as an estimator of mu square. But in that
case so if I use mu 2 hat as t 1 x then expectation of t 1 x that you have already seen that it
is sigma square plus mu square. So in that case this is biased and which does not go
to 0 which does not reduce to 0 as n goes to infinity.
So that is the fundamental thing that here the bias does not not going to 0 here the
bias is going to 0. So very natural we will prefer this one when the bias is going to
0 if you have large sum. So consider that these 2 are the estimation of mu square problem.
So now we will give the formal definition and see try to explain with the diagrams.
So the notion of this type of estimator is known as the consistent estimator and estimator
Tn which is a function of n sample size. So n is the sample size is said to be consistent
for g theta if the difference between Tn and g theta that is becoming bounded that become
very very small as n goes to infinity. So the difference between the estimated value
and the true value their gap become very very small. So in a in a if you want to see in
an interval then suppose here is g theta then the estimator will lie with the very small
neighborhood of it or if you want to visualize it in a higher dimension then already we have
shown you that the estimator will fall within a very small neighborhood of the parameter
and as a consequence the model will come close to the true model.
So that is what we are looking for. So if we are very close to the parameter the true
models will be coming very the estimated models will be coming very close to the true one.
So that is the idea. So here we are considering the mean estimation problem for the data coming
from normal mu maybe say 1 ok. We are willing to estimate mean. So x bar is the estimator
mu hat as simple as that. So the blue one is the true mean and the red one is the sorry
blue one is the estimated mean the red one is the true mean as a consequence whatever
you can see that we have drawn 25 samples and each time 25 samples drawn the process
is is iterated for 10,000 time and this histogram you can observe. So this is how the distribution
of an estimator generate eventually. In practice it happens through the collection
of data in simulation you can do by the computer and this is the estimated distribution of
x bar and this is the blue one is the mean of the all mean of sample size 25 and the
red one is the true mean which is 0. So here you can see that the true mean location and
the estimated mean average is the same. If you increase the but here you notice the spread
spread is almost from minus 0.6 to plus 0.6. The same story repeats if you increase the
sample size but the spread has become less.
Again if you increase the sample size to 500 spread has become even smaller but the center
part remains same. The true value is well captured by the estimated one. If you combine
all these three histograms so the sample size 25 with blue, 50 with green and 500 with black
if you combine them you can see these smoothed out density functions of the unbiased estimator
for mean. All of them are unbiased very nicely centered at 0 but depending on the sample
size the spreads are different but the advantage is that if we increase the sample size it
becomes very very close to the true one and as a consequence as n goes to infinity it
will converge to the true one with a very high probability which is eventually the
demand of the consistency.
Now we have seen the feature of consistency for an unbiased estimator of mu via x bar
x bar is an unbiased estimator mu hat we have done this. Now let us talk about mu square
ok as we have discussed here the if we talk about the estimation of mu square we can use
this one t 2 x which is x bar square. Now x bar square if we see the distribution what
you will observe here that if we have 25 sample sizes so x 1, x 2, x n they follows normal
0, 1 square maybe or sigma square whatever. Now what is mu square mu square is definitely
0 undoubtedly but if I use x bar square as an estimator of mu square or maybe as we
mentioned then you can see that the estimator has a certain amount of bias it is falling
here it is not close to 0 ok. Now if you increase the sample size it become
little bit closer to 0 if you increase the sample size from 50 to 500 it becomes very
very close to 0 but not exactly 0. So the consistency holds although the unbiased property
is not there. Now if you combine all these three histograms so this is the true mean
which is the red line. Now if the sample size increases from 50 to sorry 25 to 50 and finally
we have 500. So this is how the bias reduces and the consistency increases with the variance
also decreases. So ultimately it is going to the true value with a very high accuracy
which is the demanding feature for the consistency. And notice one thing whatever may it be biasness
or unbiasedness is not a very big deal as long as the estimator is consistent.
So keep this thing in mind unbiasedness is a fairy tale we often cannot attain unbiasedness
for real life problem but consistency is such a demand which we must maintain otherwise
many uncertainty in the prediction and the model building will be there which will be
not good for any practice. Here are the also the cross sectional view example the same story
that I have told you for the mean estimation. Here you see that how the fluctuation decreases.
So if I have less number of observation the fluctuation is more as long as here this blue
line we have 25 observation the green line we have 50 observation. The fluctuations become
comparatively less and when we consider the 500 observation the fluctuation is even less
but all of them are fluctuating around me. So mu hat estimation problem here and this
is this estimation problem is mu square. So here the cross sectional view gives you the
clear idea how the histograms or the density function that you have seen are looking narrower
as the sample size increases. So and finally if you have one cross section
here another cross section here another cross section here you will get three density which
are nothing but the same that one you have already seen. So this is how the consistency
notion of the consistency is present in statistical analysis which is at the same time demanding
for any learning problem if the estimator is not consistent inevitably whatever you
do the end of the day the uncertainty in prediction will be huge which is not at all a demandable
thing. Now let us go for the accuracy measure.
So accuracy measure first let us talk about bias which we have already discussed that
bias is the gap between the true one and the estimated one. The true one is the expected
value of the true one whatever made me and g theta is the value which you are willing
to estimate. So as a consequence this is the measurement of bias. So bias when I am using
tx to estimate g theta. So that is the way we try to represent and that should be true
for all parameter theta. Now notice the thing that bias when we talk about we do not use
any absolute value. So only the positive biasness negative biasness is also used positive biasness
means this expected value is larger than the true value and negative biasness is the expected
value is smaller than the true value. But in general if g theta is a vector value parameter
like beta naught beta 1 for regression then individually for beta naught beta 1 you can
talk about biasness. But as a vector it is either unbiased or it is biased. So upward
bias or positively biased negatively biased that story can be told only for one parameter
or one parametric function. If you have more than one parameter or parametric function
no point to talking about upward bias or downward bias.
Now this gap is considered in real line that means individually term by term gap you are
considering and that is the bias. If you want to accumulate them then you can take the absolute
value and take the sum or other way we try to represent the thing in terms of the square
distance. So here for one variable or one parameter the mean squared error mean squared
error so the terminology itself represents the expression. So mean for mean this is the
mean. So the mean is represented by this expectation squared error is this quantity. So Tx minus
g theta whole square that is the squared error you take the expectation and that is eventually
becomes the mean squared error. Mean squared error and that should be defined for all parameter
theta. Now if we do a little bit decomposition of this one for that you can use a simple
trick for a class 7 level not even beyond that. With inside it you use the two term
minus expectation of x sorry you just implement a adjustment negative of expectation of Tx
plus expectation of x. So this adjustment you do inside it take the square expand it
take the expectation you will be done and what you will get you will get this decomposition
which is known as a bias variance decomposition. So bias variance decomposition splits the
mean squared error into two non-negative term as it is variance it is non-negative as it
is bias squared definitely it is also non-negative. So this bias variance decomposition tells you
that how much fluctuation the estimator has and how much away it is from the true value.
Now why we prefer this one so computation of MSC is comparatively easy that is the first
fundamental thing. Second fundamental thing is this one that if the MSC of the estimator
goes to 0 as n goes to infinity then definitely the Tnx is a consistent estimate. So that
is the biggest advantage that is why people prefer mostly to go by the MSC. MSC takes
care two thing together one is the variance another is the bias. So what does it say it
says two thing that the fluctuation of the estimator is reducing MSC is going to 0 means
variance is going to 0 bias is going to 0 that means fluctuation is reducing at the
same time the estimator is going to the true value of the parameter.
So you try to observe this thing that suppose you have a scenario where this is the true
parameter theta and you have an estimator which is having distribution here and as a
consequence it has certain amount of bias. So bias means this gap. Now what is the what
is happening if the MSC is going to 0? MSC is going to 0 means you are having another
estimator as n goes to infinity its bias is reducing maybe say it is coming closer to
here from say 50 sample to 500 sample. So it is becoming closer to here and its fluctuation
the thickness that is what we have told you in the last lecture the cartosis is increased.
So now the bias has reduced and eventually as the n even more increases the fluctuation
decreases and as a consequence the bias is also so maybe the true mean is coming here.
So as a consequence the bias reduces bias is going to 0 and variance is also going to
0. So this is how when the bias and variance both
of them reduces we are going to have a consistent estimator for the parameter which is a sufficient
condition. And those type of estimator where the it is becoming unbiased as n goes to infinity
then it is known as the asymptotically unbiased estimator. Notice that for a biasness we just
use L1 norm or eventually what you know as the absolute distance. On the other hand the
MSC is using L2 norm which is also known as the Euclidean distance.
So based on Euclidean distance we construct MSC based on L1 distance or the absolute distance
if we are focusing only in the magnitude then we are using L1 norm and we are getting the
bias amount from there. So let us not make it more technical. Here I am giving you one
exercise which you can do by simulation if you are not technical enough with the language
of the subject. Still you can do the simulation that x1, x2, xn iid distribution for random
variable mu variance sigma square I am not specifying the distribution ok.
So it could be normal you can do it for normal but for normal even proving this thing is
much more easier. You can use it for normal or some other variables but keep the mean
fixed keep the variance fixed that is the idea mean fixed variance fixed. Then Tn x
is x bar s1 square is 1 upon n minus 1 xi minus x bar and s2 square 1 upon n xi minus x.
So try to check already I have done that simulation that Tn x is an unbiased estimator
for mu s1 square is an unbiased estimator of sigma square this thing little bit algebra
you have to do for your make your hand dirty and s2 square is an asymptotically unbiased
estimator as n goes to infinity it will be. For normal distribution it is pretty simple
but for non-normal distribution it requires little bit work.
Now on the contrary to our general perception that s2 square which is a biased estimator
or asymptotically unbiased estimator it has mse less compared to the mse that of the s1
which is unbiased estimator and you will be able to see that if you do the simulation.
The same story you can observe in ridge regression ridge regression I hope will be taught in
your regression course that when the inversion is not possible for x transpose x matrix the
regression fitting then we introduce a certain amount of bias.
So suppose the parameter say beta i is here if we only go for the unbiased estimator it
has a huge fluctuation. But if we go for a certain amount of bias estimator it has very
less fluctuation as a consequence it has a very less fluctuation as a consequence the
bias estimator although it is biased it will have a less mse compared to the unbiased estimator.
So it is not I mean impractical or rare situation that the biased estimator is often giving
the better mse compared to the unbiased estimator. So what is the takeaway that consistency is
the ultimate goal for an estimation or learning problem that we are looking for unbiased is
good even if we do not get unbiased we have nothing to be I mean disappointed as long
as we have an estimator which is consistent may not be unbiased that also very good for
the estimation problem.
Now we can discuss few methods of estimation one of them is the method of movement which
is a pretty simple method. Method of movement means we will estimate the parameters or through
a moment equality. So what does it mean if I have the parameter f theta and the function
f theta then we will calculate the parameter value through the equation solving and the
equations will be constructed in this form. So I am talking about two problems which you
will be able to see that how they are connected and how they are different.
So first of all x i is following normal mu sigma square. So expectation of x first order
raw moment is mu which is estimated by x bar which is 1 upon n sum over x i i running
from 1 to n. So this is the expectation. Now on the other hand sigma square variance
of x which is sigma square which is estimated by 1 upon n sum over x i minus x bar whole
square i running from 1.
So here you can see that given the data so this is from the data. So this is the data
analog of mean this is the data analog of variance. So these two things are from using
the data and these two things are theoretical. Equate them sorted here it is already sorted.
But if you consider another situation where say y i's are following gamma alpha lambda
then expectation of y equal to alpha for lambda expectation of variance of y variance of y
equal to alpha by lambda square. So in this scenario what we will have alpha upon lambda
equal to y bar sample mean as we have constructed here alpha upon lambda square equal to so
let us call that h 1 square or may be a square in this context so a square.
Now you see that the right hand side computation remains same for a given set of data but the
left hand side computation they become different as a consequence whatever we have we can solve
it very easily for alpha and lambda. Remember this thing here alpha is the shape parameter
lambda is the rate parameter. Lambda is not scale parameter here it is the rate parameter
that is why the mean has become alpha upon lambda and the variance has become alpha upon
lambda square. Now for example as many unknown parameters you have that many equations you
have to construct and finally solve them for all those unknown parameters.
So if it is k construct k such equations and it is preferred that as many lowest order
moment we can use better use that that is the way of approach. Now here for the given
set of data I have tried to show you this method of moment the true parameter for normal
is sorry. True parameter is considered to be 1.3 and the method of moment estimate has
become this one the true sigma is this and the method of moment estimator is this one.
So as a consequence if that means we have used this model and as a consequence you can
see that how the curves become close to one another this is the CDF the black one is the
true one the red one is the estimated one and how close they are even with the method
of moment estimation and this is how the histogram of the data and the PDFs are also very close
enough and there will be certain situations where the moments theoretically will not exist.
One such example is if we consider fx equal to 1 by pi 1 plus x square. So this is a situation
which is known as the quasi distribution this is quasi distribution with mu equal to 0 mu
is the location parameter sigma is the scale parameter 1 or or another random variable
for discrete setup you can consider if I am remembering correctly say k square pi square
6 I mean k equal to 1 after so on. So if if we consider this summation this type of situation
the mean does not exist as a consequence the higher dimension does not exist. So sorry
higher higher moments does not exist. So we cannot go for the method of moment estimation
we require some other estimator which are typically used as maximum likelihood estimator.
So let us have a break and after that we will continue with the maximum. So now let us continue
with estimation process which is eventually a learning process and this is how any model
parameter can be estimated or trained the model training can be done.
Now the fundamental aspect of model training now what we will discuss is based on the cost
function. So and in a general class it is known as an aim estimator two examples we
will talk about will not go in the details calculation of all of them but how and their
approaches and how the mechanism should work that is the thing we will talk in this setup.
I am sure that in future you will get the scope of specific you are working out all
this thing in a specific examples and for real data today hypothetically or theoretically
let us conceptualize the thing later on you will have more details examples and the hands
on associated to it for the time being let us see how what are the core of the thing
and how it works. So first of all the maximum likelihood estimate which is a very popular
estimator in statistics and machine learning this estimator tries to visualize or that
consider the data in such a way that we have observed a data that means it is the most
likely data.
So I am repeating we observe a data because it is the most likely data and we want to
get out information based on this assumption. So if I consider a particular probability
distribution very simply I am saying say this is one probability for one probability for
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 so on and on. Very easily one can identify that the 3 is the most likely
data of this distribution. On the other hand if you consider a continuous distribution this
is the value which is most likely ok for which the pdf or pmf has the highest peak that is
eventually the more. Now here as we consider this one it is a pdf or pmf so the parameter
is unknown or may be a fixed constant may be known may be unknown and the probability
distribution you can see accordingly. Now if you the story of the maximum likelihood
is told in this way that suppose x1, x2, xn they are the random sample from a particular
distribution f theta they are iid that means they are random sample theta is the unknown
parameter from the parameter space then the joint pdf of x1, x2, xn is this that means
they are product and then comes the notion of the likelihood.
So what does it say that I have the joint pdf x1, x2, xn based on that and a parameter
theta. Now if I plug in the values of x i's with whichever numerical value I have observed
from the data then it will be a function of theta then it will be a function of theta
only what we write in the form l theta given x. After plugging in the value of x i's in
the data from the data we consider the expression of the joint density as a function of the
parameter which is known as the likelihood function and we want to maximize the likelihood
for the estimation of theta. Why we do that the idea is same as I have
told you that we assume that the data is the most likely data that is why we have observed.
So eventually we are doing a back calculation or back calculation such that we can portray
the given data as the most likely data or the given data is the mode of the distribution.
So with an example let us diagrammatic example let us try to conceptualize then we will go
for the mathematics. So suppose we have an x follows normal mu 1 sigma 1 for the simplicity
and the observed value of x is 5.45. So this is observed and that value is here.
Now for which pdf this 5.45 has the maximum height. So the pdf will look based on the
normal distribution. So fx is e to the power minus half x minus mu divided by 1 whole square
divided by root 2 pi into 1. So this is the pdf. Now if I choose the particular value
of mu equal to 1.5 then this is the black pdf and its value at 5.45 you can see it is here.
Then if I choose the mu equal to 3.5 then it is the yellow pdf and its value the value
of 5.45 evaluated on this yellow pdf is here. On the other hand if we choose the value of
mu as 6.5 then we have the green pdf for which the value of 5.45 evaluated on the green pdf
is here. At the same time if we choose the mu value as 5 then the pdf value is here and
finally if we choose the pdf value as 5.45 then the pdf value is here. So eventually
this is the search process. So I am searching for all possible values of mu and for each
value of mu I am calculating the expression e to the power minus half 5.45 minus mu whole
square divided by pi that is l mu given data. So this is how it looks and for each mu I
am calculating this value this value this value. So for different different values of
mu I am getting this number. I am looking for that mu which will give me the highest
value and that is what is done by the maximum likelihood estimate.
So now let us make it formal that l theta given data is this function. We want to maximize
this function with respect to theta r max means eventually the maxima that means the
value of theta for which l theta is attaining maximum or eventually it is the log of l theta
is attaining the maximum. It is we can use log because log is a function which is defined
on the positive part of real axis and pdf are always non negative. If the pdf value
the joint density value is 0 then it is not in the competition. If it is non 0 we can
take the log and we can compare often taking log is much more easier that that is the thing
you can see for normal distribution itself.
Because even even if you take the log if you take the log of this expression rest all of
them will become constant ultimately you have to deal with x i x minus mu by 1 whole square.
So this is the expression the negative half. So after taking log you will get this type
of expression. So dealing with this expression is much more easier than the exponent and
so on and so forth. So taking log is often useful. So this is how maximum likelihood
estimation is often obtained. MLE has few properties like it need not be unique well
we can show you certain examples. It need not be an unbiased estimator. So for example
1 upon n sum over x i minus x bar whole square i running from 1 to n that is the MLE of sigma
square which is a biased estimator. MLE need not be unique. So MLE is always a consistent
estimator. This proof is little long but it holds. MLE is asymptotically normally distributed
up to certain regularity condition. If the range of the random variable is free from
the parameter that means it is not like normal distribution, binomial distribution or something.
Not of this form, not of this form that x follows uniform 0 theta. So here the range
depends on 0 to theta. So upper bound is given. The range depends on 0 to theta in that case
it will not hold and likelihood is mootly differentiable after third order derivative
and the integration can be interpreted. So these are the technical requirements. Apart
from that likelihood is a very well behaving estimator often difficult to get but that
is a computational issue. For that people do many Markovchen Monte Carlo method or people
also do gradient descent method. All those types of optimization techniques can be used
for getting the solution but that the difficulty does not stop us for obtaining the solution.
Here let me give you one example where the consistency uniqueness is a issue. Suppose
instead of normal you have the density like this e to the power minus x minus mu mod instead
of square it is mod divided by 2 fx. Suppose this is the density and if you have n such
observation then it is sum over running i running from 1 to n and 2 to the power n it
will be. As a consequence you can see that it will look like this. Normal is this smooth
and this is double exponential. A potential model for the error distribution when sometime
normal you are not using or you are doing a regression problem when the error are considered
the measurement error is considered to be the absolute distance then this is a very
potential one for the error model. Now if you go by this one the MLE of mu is
the median is the sample median. And in the last lecture we have discussed that the sample
median can be unique if the observation n if n is got to keep odd number of observation
then it has a unique median if n is even then it has non-unique median. So as a consequence
MLE can be non-unique this is the counter is. So here I have just tried to demonstrate.
Suppose you are getting many messages in your either cell phone or WhatsApp or many. So
first 10 messages of your first 10 messages of the day you are considering and how many
of them are the proper message and rest all are promo or you can consider the how many
of them are promo messages and rest of them are valid message.
So these are 50 such days trial hypothetically 50 such days trial and you are willing to
check what is the proportion of the promo messages are entering. So these are the these
are the 50 observations that we have and from there I am constructing the binomial PDF.
So P to the power x i 1 minus P to the power n so 10 minus x i product over i running from
1 to 50. So 50 days I have taken the data and definitely n choose x so this is 10 choose
50. So this is how the PDF looks and product over all the PDF and we are looking for the
value of so this is L P given data. So this is the likelihood function for the parameter
P and given the data x 1, x 2, x n. So 50 observations I have I want to maximize the
likelihood. So here for simplicity I have done it for grid search and here you can see
that it has taken certain peak and the base value is the estimate of the P.
Now instead of the product of the densities if I take the log likelihood then the same
story you will be observing the location of the maxima has remain unaltered but the function
have changed and both in both of the cases MLE is observed to be 7.72 where the true
value true value was 0.7. So it is a close one based on the 50 observation if you increase
the observation it will get much more closer value.
Finally speaking we can what we should do we should take log of this we should take derivative
with respect to P equate with 0 and solve it ultimately P hat MLE will come as say x
bar whatever observation x bar divided by 10. So that will be the MLE in this situation.
So it is a very simple problem that one can very easily do but my emphasize for this example
was that if you take log the maxima will be unchanged and taking after taking log the
problem much much will be much more easier to handle and well here the advantage is that
that you can take the differentiation but differentiation is one of the way for obtaining
the maxima even if it is not differentiable like this function that we have discussed.
If the function is not differentiable with with respect to the parameter still we can
manage to obtain the minima or the maxima whatever we are looking for if it is MLE depending
on the minimum of this exponent is eventually gives us the maximum. So ultimately it is
an MST. So this is the take away from this example. Now the problem becomes much more
interesting if we have more than one distribution and that more than one distribution and their
mixture. So let me just try to emphasize the thing that mixture distribution means you
have two competing or two or more such distributions one is this one another might be this one.
So end of the day what is happening with certain probability I will go to this rate distribution
and draw a sample with certain probability I will go to this rate distribution and draw
a sample with 1 minus that probability I will go to this distribution and a sample.
Again I will flip a coin I will go to this distribution I will draw a sample again I
will flip a coin I will go might be again going to this distribution and draw a sample.
So in this way the mixture distribution is constructed or conceptualized it is not like
that I will have an observation from here and I will have an observation from here and
get a linear combination of that it is not that one. Mixed there means we will draw from
only one distribution at each time which distribution I will draw that will be a probabilistic
decision. So mixture distribution is a very good model
for the more complex densities because eventually the density appear to us like maybe like this.
So this red curve or the blue curve will not be known visible to us we will only have this
pink curve as a whole. So the mixture distribution can be used for more complex or sophisticated
data. Hidden mark for hidden markup model it is a definite application. Incomplete data
model also can be treated in a mixture distribution. So without going for the technicalities I am
just giving you the s m that it is again a maximum likelihood problem, m stivation problem
on, but it has a certain variable which is missing that means from which distribution
the data is coming that level is missing. So here the z is the level in substance.
So it has been integrated out with respect to z and we have the likelihood of the parameter
and the data. This type of maximum likelihood problem is solved in EM algorithm. In EM algorithm
it has two steps one step is the expectation step. So in there the expectation is taken
for the unobserved value of the data given the observed part and the estimated parameter
at stage t for the iteration, for the likelihood we take the expectation and then we write
the complete likelihood and we do the maximization and repeat the process until you convert to
a particular precise solution. So here I am trying to show you another example
the source of the data is given. So eventually the data will look like this. We will have
no distinction from where the data are coming. So this is a typical example of the mixture
distribution and originally if you want to look then this is one distribution this is
another distribution. But end of the day we see only the black one. The job is to find
the parameter mu 1, mu 2, sigma 2, sigma 1 and this is pi 1, pi 2 such that pi 1 plus
pi 2 equal to 1. So all these parameters are supposed to be estimated in a mixture distribution.
So here is another example of the data Gaussian mixture model. So here you can see that there
are two mixture distribution but eventually it is looking little bit non Gaussian because
they are mixed. They are not the linear combination of normal. Linear combination of normal is
again normal that is the thing we will show you in the next lecture. But here what you
can see that the this blue the green one yellow one both of them are normal itself but they
are mixture is no longer normal ok. So this is how the mixture distribution looks and
we can evaluate or the parameter values from the data.
So here I am showing you one example for the sake of demonstration that 272 observation
of two variables we will go one variable first and then for the two variables. So this is
an usually known as the faithful data for the eruption of a spring. So it has two component
the eruption time and the waiting time. So there is a gap between two eruptions that
is the waiting time and when the eruption starts how long it will continue that is the
eruption time. So we have assumed that there are two normal
distribution one with parameter mu 1 sigma 1 another with parameter mu 2 sigma 2 and
with probability p for the shorter waiting time probability 1 minus p for the longer
waiting. So the marginal pdf is a linear combination of the pdf it is not the linear combination
of the data. Now marginal pdf is the linear combination of the or the convex combination
of the pdf. Now in each step each step and m step and the steps I have already explicitly
written and the code is have provided to you. I know only art so I have written the code
in art you can copy paste the code in charity we will get it converted to python whatever
language you want. So now here if Z equals to 1 it is giving
the shorter length if it is 0 for the longer length of waiting time. So this is how the
expectation of Z i is at each step and then again write down the complete likelihood.
So notice this is the marginal likelihood this is marginal when the labels are not known
this is the complete when the labels are plugged in. So based on that we repeat the process
and after repetition we will converge to a particular value which are close enough to
one another and in that case we stop the iteration.
And here you can see that there is a two such pillars multimodal distributions we call one
is fitted for the green one another is the red one and the combined pdf which is the
marginal pdf that is shown in the dotted blue card. So this is for one dimension and for
two dimension also here the eruption time and waiting time. So for one margin whatever
this is the eruption and the waiting so whatever we have done this is for waiting time.
So for this one we have done we have another component which is the duration of eruption
and combining together you have this is one cluster this is another cluster. So this is
eventually a clustering problem solving. So this is you can say it is a mixture Gaussian
fitting you can see it is an EM algorithm problem but end of the day it is solving clustering
problem. So that is why the understanding of the MLE is very much important and it is
a model driven clustering problem. It is not like K-means clustering it is a model driven
clustering problem we have the parameter we have the distribution and eventually we are
considering the data as a mixture of different models.
So here we can obtain all the parameter values of specific distribution and the mixing probabilities
as well through EM algorithm. Now with a short note to another criteria of estimation which
is very popular for regression known as the least square estimation. So here as of now
we have maximized the likelihood so one maximization problem another is least square estimation
that means square error is minimized. So that is that could be another criteria of estimation.
So consider the simple linear regression model that y the mean value of y is a linear function
of x and consider the normal distribution for the error. So as a consequence yi's are
following normal distribution as always data given x i's are constants yi's are random
variable and epsilon i's ok. So I have ok so epsilon i's are the error ok. So they
are random error they are independently and identically distributed ok.
Now the least square problem is for one two variables it is very simple you can consider
the true value true value and the predicted value their difference make it square and
try to minimize this square error. You can take it absolute value that is also a valid
problem but the advantage of squaring it is it will be differentiable. If we take absolute
value here it will not be differentiable ok. Now with a notation s suffix x y is this beta
if we differentiate this quantity with respect to beta naught beta 1 and equate with 0 solve
it with doing all this stuff we will get this one and this. I am not doing this thing because
nowadays software will do it for you ok. So these simple things will be easily dealt by
the software. So beta 1 hat can be written down in this form s suffix x y divided by
s suffix double x s suffix double x means it will be sum over x i minus x bar whole square.
So each y i's will be replaced by x i itself ok similarly y i and beta naught is this.
So you can very easily get the prediction line as this one. So if you plug in a new value
of x naught you will get the value of y. So this is the prediction problem as well as
the estimation problem together. Now in statistics the inferential problem is very much important
because we need to know whether these values are significantly close to certain number
or not or they are close to 0 or not. So these are the thing that is very much important
in statistical aspect and sometime of the machine learning problem as well. So here the schematic
diagram that this is the red line is the fitted line the blue dots are the data. So this much
is the gap between the data and the predicted line and e i is the error we want to minimize
the square n. So that is the whole idea. Here is a complete worked out example that
x is a regressor variable feature variable y is the response variable as a consequence
we call calculate all the necessary thing and finally end up with this prediction line.
This is a very simple structure anybody and everybody can do. Notice one thing as of now
this prediction structure we have never used normality. Normal assumption of the error
we have done at the very beginning but we have never used normality.
So up to this much prediction line through least square method you can get without assumption
of normality but if you need to check the significant value for each of the parameter
beta naught, beta 1 and so on and so forth you require the normality assumption which
makes the life much more easier. Otherwise some resampling techniques can be implemented.
We can make it more general for more feature earlier it was only up to this much. Now you
can incorporate more variables more feature vector this thing we will talk in the great
details in the next lecture. And the similar way we can construct the model but here the
least square condition will the entire model will look like y is the response variable
x is the feature matrix, beta is the parameter, epsilon is the error vector. So this is error
vector, true error vector this is response and this is feature and this is the model
parameter. As a consequence we need to minimize the
least square error and obtain the value of the beta. Now let us see that the square error
so y is a vector x is a matrix beta is a vector end of the day y minus x beta is also a vector
n component vector. So that vector transpose the same vector it eventually boils down to
this expression for more variables of x i ok. Here you have only one x value here you
have k such component of x i and the same thing in you can write in a matrix notation
like this. Now open the I mean just follow the note from the previous lecture there we
have given you how to differentiate with respect to a vector, differentiate this entire expression
with respect to the beta vector this component will vanish you will have contribution from
here you will have contribution from here and equate with a 0 vector solve it you will
get beta hat that means the estimated value of beta as this.
Now here is the simple linear regression structure what is the straight line so this is another
important data of people often use the cells with respect to the advertisement in different
platform TV or TV and radio. So if I use only TV it is a simple linear regression problem
if I have more than one regressors then it is eventually giving us a plane. So the red
dots are the data and the plane is the fitted regression surface of the plane. Now few geometric
property that is important here to be noticed that if I want to predict the value of y what
I can do I can use x and use the estimated value of beta which eventually gives me a
matrix like this multiplied by y and interestingly this matrix is the projection matrix of any
vector y in the feature space. Feature space means whatever x matrix I have if I consider
all possible linear combination of the column x 1 x 2 x and first column is 1 and so first
column is 1. If I consider all possible linear combination of all these columns then the
space that we generate that is known as the feature space. So as a consequence this PX
matrix what it what it is doing here any y variable response variable it brings it down
to the feature space and regression is only that nothing more than that can be done by
a prior regression. And what is the estimated error that is the true value of y minus the
estimated value of y which can be written as identity minus Px into y.
Now you have this e vector and this estimated vector or the predicted vector y take their
dot product and do the calculation you will get 0 vector which means that this predicted
value and the true value so this is the error. So this much is the error and this is the
prediction they are perpendicular to each other geometrically that is given here. And
if we consider the covariance of them it will eventually become 0 which eventually lead
to independence if the normal distribution assumption is present otherwise not. So covariance
0 is will be okay but independence will be only because of normality this thing we will
elaborate in the next lecture. And added advantage of this model is with
another dataset I am just schematic diagram I am giving. So here is the stock 1 is predicted
via stock 2 and stock 3 with a simple linear regression model say y equal to stock 1 is
beta 0 plus beta 1 x 1 plus beta 2 x 2. So this is stock 2 this is stock 3 but if we add
so based on this you get this model but if we add another component if we add another
component to it say beta 3 x 1 x 2 that is also possible. If we add another component
still we can solve that problem but the model will become much more adjustable with the
interaction effect of stock 1 and stock 2 and instead of straight flat plane you have
a twisted plane or twisted surface. So this is what the generalization of interaction
we can do in the model but everything falls under the least square minimization problem
and which we can solve through the square error minimization as an M estimation problem
for entire setup. So before concluding let us have a demonstration of this EM algorithm
whatever I have shown you here if the software supports let me just give it a try RStudio
okay so that may I have the screen yes thank you.
So that data set that we have already talked about the waiting time for eruption and by
various two normal distributions we are trying to show their EM approach for solution let
us see the diagram. So you see that the histograms are fixed from the data and as the iteration
moves the densities are adjusting themselves such that it will converge to an optimal situation
where the successive iterations are almost closed enough for obtaining the true parameter
value. So deliberately I have chosen the parameter which is a little bit away from the true one
and such that the convergence takes little bit more time.
So here okay so finally we have got this one. So with the iteration you can see that
it has taken 32 iterations to have almost consecutively similar value in the successive
iteration. So this is how EM approaches but there is a chance that it might get stuck
with the local optimal value. So I think I should stop now if I have queries let us
have it. The code is appended with the BDF. Could you please provide an example of active
and passive. So in active so whatever the learning you are seeing in EM algorithm that
is an active learning. Eventually we do not say much about the parameters the data itself
at the algorithm itself adjust with the thing but in passive learning if we specify the
parameter labeling and we estimate individually the parameter then that is a passive learning.
What was the other name of the online learning in statistics? So online learning in statistics
sometimes is known as a surveillance process. So if a process is going on it is often done
for signals as well as the statistical quality control. That if a process is set on if certain
changes happening we are supposed to detect the change as early as possible. So that is
a surveillance problem or online term is nowadays also very much popular in statistical learning.
But for the static learning what is that is known as the retrospective study and it is
not exactly online but say for example phase 4 clinical trials when study suppose when
people take medicine for a particular disease or a person is taking then the person usually
take more than one disease a more than one medicine for the treatment. And if the person
is getting some ADR adverse drug reaction or the side effect like what we say then there
is a repository you can report that because of this group of medicines I am having this
much of this side effect and then it is a causal analysis which is done at the phase
4 of clinical trials that for which combination of or for the which medicine this side effect
is happening. So it is also important that as early as possible
the detection is done it will be better to take a preventive action for the entire system
of the or the fatality. Are we trying to estimate the distribution of the given data set using
the statistic and assuming the model yes. So data set given model assumed and statistics
are used to obtain the parameter value or approximate the parameter value which is nothing but
the either in statistics it is estimation process in machine learning it is a learning
process as simple as that.
Another non-statistic background and getting very difficult for understanding the class
can you please suggest how can I proceed a general query from many participants definitely.
So it is recommended that you first take up one very easy reading book and one very easy
going YouTube lecture whatever is possible for you. Easy reading book I think I have
suggested one that Miller and Miller's Jay Freud's mathematical statistic that is a book
what anybody will be able to read or maybe one more book I will suggest the organizer
will communicate to you the from that book I have taken this regression example model
fitting this that one no not this. So another book maybe I will suggest which will be even
more easier but at least one one basic book you have to see read out otherwise it will
be definitely problematic.
And in YouTube lecture well there are many lectures available in the website you can
see one lecture series is also available at my home page in Google my Google home page
if you find it is useful you can go for it basic probability statistics and little bit
of inference is completely done there with required details and examples it has been
worked out completely. So I hope it will be useful for you book suggestion I will share
with you one I have shared and two book suggestion is already there in my home page also one
is little advanced and the another one is basic the Miller's Miller is very basic another
one also I will upload there or maybe I will share with you coordinator thank you can you
please elaborate more on IID distribution of the data provided an example are there some
other types of data distribution similar criteria. So what does it mean IID so we say X and
Y are IID or X1, X2, Xn are IID IID means independently and identically distributed.
So I am talking about X and Y such that it will be general can be generalized for X1
so suppose the core is this suppose this is the CDF of X, so that is capital F X, FXT
this is the CDF of X and if Y has to be IID with X that means the CDF of Y will overlap
on the CDF of X. So it might be GYT but whatever may be F or G you call does not matter so
this is GYT they will overlap that means probability X less than equal to T is same as probability
capital Y less than equal to T for or T belongs to real number this is one of the aspects
for simplicity I am writing in this way and second thing is the impact X will not influence
the distribution of Y, Y will not influence the distribution of X so they are independent.
So that means probability XY they belongs to the set A cross B as a Cartesian product
which is probability X belongs to A, Y into probability Y belongs to P and this AB is
of this type of set minus infinity to T1 minus infinity to T2 this is the technical meaning.
So they are not interacting with each other so they are not influencing one another distribution
that means independence and whatever may be that point you choose their probability will
be same up to that point that is identical CDF these two combiningly known as independently
and identically distributed which distribution that is that we are not specifying but these
two common features are shared among themselves and you can extend the same story for infertility.